Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in
the second chapter of the Quran to be
revealed to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
The first verses that we spoke of those
first 10 verses
they were revealed to the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam at an
earlier time.
We know that the very first seven verses
or some scholars say five of
were the next thing to be revealed to
the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
after
sometime after
the remaining part of
was revealed.
Now how do we know this? Well, we know
this because of the tone and the subject
matter of the chapter.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,"
he says, "And when the horn is blown,
the horn that will commence the day of
judgment,
then that is a day that is very, very
difficult
and it will be a day that will not be
easy upon the disbelievers.
Notice the wording here. He says,
"Subhan,
and when the horn is blown,
this horn is held by
he is one of the eight angels that bear
and carry the throne of Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
This horn was described to us by the
prophet sallall.aii Wasam
as being a horn of light
and that is
one of the greatest
one of the greatest angels of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
and al- Mustad the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said
[Silence]
He said,
"Allah has given me permission
to describe to you all
an angel from those angels that carry
the throne of Allah.
What it the distance between his earlobe
to his shoulder
is 700 years travel.
These are the angels that carry the
throne of Allah and Israel.
is one of those angels and he has been
given the great honor and responsibility
of blowing into the horn. Now blowing
into the horn, how many blows into the
horn will there be? The scholars of
Islam differ on this issue
because the Quran mentions
three
blows into the horn.
He mentions subhanahu
[Silence]
he mentions subhanahu waala that when
the horn is blown the people will rise
up out of their graves. waves and come
forward to be judged by Allah. So this
is one
one blow into the horn we know will be
the the blow that commences the day of
judgment.
Everything will
have its soul returned to him. Everyone
will have his soul returned to him and
will be brought up out of his grave and
come forth to be judged by Allah.
In another verse, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says
he mentions that
a blow into the horn will cause mass
hysteria.
an incredible terror
and horror that will fill the hearts of
everyone in the heavens and the earth
except for those whom Allah has exempted
from that fear.
In another
verse, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions
he mentions that when the horn is blown,
everyone in the heavens and in the earth
will be struck down.
Will be struck down. So here we have
three blows into the horn. seemingly.
And so
as such, because of these three
different descriptions of the results of
blowing into that horn, some of the
scholars like
stipulates that there are three blows
into the horn on the day of judgment.
However, the majority of the scholars of
Islam and the majority of the scholars
of Tapsi, as Iben Kir has mentioned in
his taps, are of the opinion that these
are actually two blows into the horn,
not three. They are two.
One blow,
everyone in the heavens and in the earth
will be struck with fear and terror
and will be struck down. So that is the
blow into the horn that will end and
obliterate
this world, all that is on it, and the
heavens and the earth as we know them.
When that horn is blown on that day,
it will be blown upon the worst of
mankind that have ever existed.
The prophet Sam
said in Muslim
he said the hour will commence the day
of judgment when the sky is split open
when the earth is shook to the point
where the where the mountains on the
earth turn to dust again is how
violently the earth will shake. It will
destroy the mountains and flatten the
earth.
The seas and the oceans will dry up and
in their place fire will ignite.
The stars will streak down the sky in
chaos.
Everything
that I have described to you are
descriptions
of what will happen when
blows into that horn and the day of
judgment will commence upon the second
blowing. This first blow into the horn
will end the life of this world.
everything. A person may say,
"How is it that the hour or that first
blow into the horn will
be upon the worst of humanity?" Where
are the Muslim
at that time? There are no more Muslim
upon the earth.
There is no more Quran upon the earth.
And the prophet Sam
said that a night will come.
He said, "A night will come when Allah
will collect back every verse of the
Quran
and there will not remain a single verse
of the Quran upon the earth. Person will
open whatever there is of a mus and it
will be empty. There will be no more
verses of the Quran. No person on earth
will know a single verse of the Quran
anymore. The only thing left in the
mouths or upon the tongues of the Muslim
of that day will be
that's all they will know of Islam
anymore. It will completely be gone. The
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us that Allah will take back all
of the Quran and there will not be any
Muslims anymore.
There will just be pockets of Muslims
here and there who all they know of
Islam isahill.
They will say as is inbah
we remember our forefathers used to
sayahill.
So we say it but we do not know what it
means. They will not be making salah.
There will be no giving zakah. The
pillars of Islam will be forgotten by
the people at this time. Then the Quran
will be collected and then
an animal will come out upon the people.
The scholars differ. Does this animal
come out before the sun rises from the
west or does this animal come out after?
It said
this and that. But what is apparent is
that the sun will rise from the west.
a considerable amount of time before
this animal emerges upon the people.
This animal will come out and speak to
the people in an intelligible language
and will brand every person as a
believer or a disbeliever.
This is after the sun rises from the
west. And the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam said when the sun rises
from the west everyone upon the earth
will simultaneously
and immediately believe.
However, their belief will be rejected
at that point. The door of repentance
will be closed and salvation will have
come to an end.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us that near the end of time
there will be as is in Muslim a wind
a a a kind of air that will move through
the earth and take the life of every
believing man and woman
from the human human beings upon the
earth and there will only remain
disbelievers upon that day. I know that
when we speak about these issues, many
of us will be listening and say, "Well,
how does that happen? How is that going
to happen?" It will happen. How it
happens is probably unfathomable to us
at this point.
However, this is what our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam has told us. As for
us trying to understand how these things
will occur, Allah,
this is something we will only come to
realize the knowledge of if we see it.
That's the only way. A man came to the
prophet sallall.aii Wasam
after having heard a verse in the Quran
where Allah says that those who have
disbelieved or those who have rejected
the message of Allah that Allah will
gather them on the day of judgment and
they will be walking on their faces
upside down.
A man came and asked the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam how will
they be walking on their faces he's
trying to imagine how does this happen
the prophet sallallahu alaii wasallam
asked him the one who has made humanity
to walk on its legs
is he not able to make humanity walk on
its face he said yes of course
this is the answer that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi Wasam gave he didn't
explain to him how this will happen.
It's inconsequential.
If you were to know how this happens, it
would not increase your faith and iota.
It does not affect it is not a knowledge
that is necessary for you or I to know.
What is necessary is for us to know that
it will happen. How? Allah.
And so the only ones that will remain
upon the earth are the most wicked of
humanity. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said humanity will be of such
wickedness
and such and such shamelessness
that men and women will fornicate with
one another in the streets. And the best
amongst them will be a person who says,
"If you only just took it out of the
street to the side of the street so that
we could pass by and you wouldn't
interrupt the traffic." This is the best
of people amongst them. This is the
closest they will come to commanding the
good or forbidding the evil.
After this, the prophet sallall.aii
said in Muslim, the horn will then be
blown. A man will be buying a piece of
fabric and when they hear that horn
being blown,
he will extend the money to give. And
when they hear it, everyone will freeze
and his hand will freeze out of terror.
And the man giving the merchandise will
freeze.
And before that they will notice that
the animals are unruly
because the animals sense that something
is happening. Something is going to
happen.
The Kaa will have been destroyed by
then.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam's masid will be as he described
to where foxes and wild animals will
urinate in the place where his member
once stood.
The hour will be established upon these
people.
And so Allah describes
what this first blow into the horn will
affect the effect that it will have. It
will strike everyone in the heavens and
the earth with black terror, a wave of
terror that will make them as if they
are drunk and mindless.
And it will strike down everyone in the
heavens and the earth except for those
whom Allah has exempted.
After that there will be 40
of silence. 40 days 40 years
there will be no one alive except for
Allah.
No other living thing in the heavens or
in the earth. All of the angels
everyone.
And then Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will
bring is back to life. He will give him
the horn again. He will blow into the
horn. And the souls will then match up
and be married with their respective
bodies of their hosts. And people will
come forth from their graves to be
judged by Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
And so when the horn is blown,
That is a day which will indeed be a day
of severity and extreme difficulty
upon the disbelievers.
Not easy in any way. It will be very
uneasy for the disbeliever.
[Silence]
40 years plus 40 days.
[Arabic recitation]
will be the scholars differ. Is it days
days we have here on earth? Or is
it Allah said that a day with your
Lord is a a thousand years of your
of what we experience? So is it a
thousand is it 40 days of our days or is
it 40 days of the days of with Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala Allah?
Now,
and just a reminder, tomorrow is J.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam has
said that the most beloved
salah to Allah throughout the week is
in the masid in J on the morning of J.
If you don't usually come for fud and it
is reasonable and possible you want to
choose a day to start to get into that
habit tomorrow the j is a very very good
place to start now.